[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello, and welcome
to episode number 64 of the
weekly Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very,
very happy, very excited
about everything that
is going on right now.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty crazy.
We are just getting
into Cloud Next,
and we're here at the Cloud
Next Community Summit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so we're
recording this the day before.
So we're recording this--
it's Tuesday.
Tomorrow, when this
will be released,
it's day number
one of Cloud Next,
so we thought we would
join the community summit,
talk to some people about
what they'll be learning today
and what they're excited
about for Cloud Next.
So you yourself if you're going
to be at Cloud Next attending,
you can watch it or, later on,
watch the recording on YouTube.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
just so you're aware,
this episode will be a little
bit short, but don't fret.
Everything's OK.
What we're going to be doing
is doing daily episodes
with interviews--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For
the rest of our lives.
MARK MANDEL: No, not for
Oh my god, no.
We're going to be
doing daily interviews
on the floor with people at
Next, speakers, people we find,
interesting people.
I'm sure you will all love it.
So that you can actually
hear about Next if you're
unable to attend,
or if you're at next
and you want some possible
real-time information
about sessions coming up, you
can also listen in as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
if you're at Next,
we are on the ground floor, we
have a Google Cloud Platform
podcast booth, and
it looks pretty cool.
So come say hi.
We have t-shirts.
MARK MANDEL: We have t-shirts,
and we have stickers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah, cool stickers.
And we have many colors, too.
[INAUDIBLE] [LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So why don't we get
started with the interviews we
have today?
We're going to start with Kalev.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
Kalev Leetaru a good friend
of the podcast because
we talked already
about his project,
GDELT, with [INAUDIBLE].
So let's go talk to him.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
here today with Kalev Leetaru.
Hi, Kalev, how are you doing?
KALEV LEETARU: It's great
to be here with you guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
going to be talking today
about the Cloud Summit.
But before we do
that, why don't you
tell us like in two sentences,
who are you and what do you do?
KALEV LEETARU: So I run an
open data project called
the GDELT project,
which looks at open data
around the world,
especially news media,
and uses a whole range of
Google Cloud technologies
to process this to really try
to understand what's happening
around the world each day,
and to really connect us
more together as a world so that
very few of us have visited,
say, Burundi recently.
To be able to bring
the world together,
to see what's happening
in Burundi, or in Syria,
or over here in this
corner of the world,
to bring the world
together so we
really see what's
happening around us
and can build empathy and
understand the world around us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know you are
a very good friend of Felipe
[INAUDIBLE] from our team,
so you use a lot of BigQuery.
What other products do you use?
KALEV LEETARU: Oh,
I love BigQuery.
I mean, BigQuery
is amazing to be
able-- you think about
the amounts of data
that I generate, the to look
through billions of records,
the ability to fold
that data, so BigQuery
is a huge piece of this.
Google Compute
Engine, obviously,
making immense use of that.
Google Cloud Storage,
it's amazing to be
able to generate a data
file, shove out to storage,
and it's just infinite.
If a million people start
downloading that file,
you don't worry about it.
Most recently, I
actually started
using the Cloud ML tool.
So Cloud Vision, so actually
processing global news imagery
through Cloud Vision to Kalev,
what's the visual narrative?
Because today most
of what we do,
we deal with text usually
when we process the world.
But we forget the fact
that visual so important.
So much in the news imagery.
I was using Cloud Image-- or
Cloud Vision doing-- actually
applying cloud natural
language, so we're
starting to really
explore what can we
use of that to really understand
the news in ways we've never
been able to before.
Did a number of experiments
with Cloud Speech
and found just incredible
being able to transcribe
across the world's languages.
And so really starting to
leverage all these tools
that are out there.
And that's what I love.
It's really within the
Google environment.
A, It's infinitely scalable,
but, B, the plug and play.
I mean, the fact that
I could literally
make an API call and
say, here's an image.
Tell me what's in this
image, give me everything
you know about that,
and I don't have
to worry about learning
TensorFlow or learning
all this stuff.
But knowing that, in
the future, those--
the pathway is there
so that if I decide,
you know what, I want to build
a custom model to do this,
I know that the
infrastructure is
there to drop that in and
deploy it at those same scales.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, well, we're here
at the Community Summit
for GCP Next or for Cloud Next.
What has been exciting?
What have you been seeing today?
KALEV LEETARU:
Oh, I've loved it.
I mean, meeting all
these Google folks,
especially it's a different
community of folks
than I typically interact with.
It's been great seeing
these other sides.
I mean, hearing, especially
things like security
and how Google, you
know, has invested
so much in allowing to create a
secure cloud, a scalable cloud.
I'm seeing all these
different sides.
It's been really exciting
to me to actually hear
from Google itself.
And yeah, no, it's
been fantastic here.
And you know, and looking
to the rest of the week,
it's so exciting to just--
I mean, it's really
amazing, as someone
who has lived in
the supercomputing
world for a number
of years, it's just
amazing to be out here and see
the scale that Google operates
at.
It's really like time
traveling into the future.
And especially being
from the Washington area,
you know, it's amazing
coming out here and spending,
you know, a couple of
days just-- basically,
it's almost like you're
sort of time traveling.
You're spend a couple
of days in the future,
where it's like you know, here
is things that you've never
been able to dream of
before, and they're actually
reality available today.
It's just-- it's
incredibly exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's amazing.
So before we finish,
what are the single thing
or announcement that you
know about that you're
looking at the most forward to?
KALEV LEETARU: There's
no single thing,
and I think that's actually what
excites me so much about Google
is it's really easy to--
most companies kind of fall
into that, you know, that
single thing where you say,
oh yeah, they do this.
To me, I'm excited--
looking over the next
couple of days, the talks
that I'm most excited about
range from scalability
and infrastructure if you're
doing things at quote, unquote,
"Google scale"-- and the fact
that that's actually a term,
"Google scale" is amazing.
But I'm really--
I'm particularly
excited about the big data side.
Like what are the things
like BigQuery and the things
of being able to deal with data
where you don't have to-- you
can--
long story short,
things like BigQuery,
where, historically,
people like me,
we had to limit the
questions we asked
to our abilities or the tools
that we could bring together.
Where BigQuery, I
don't even think about
is this question
tractable anymore.
I just do it.
I just get that answer.
To quote Han Solo from
"Star Wars," he says,
"I never ask that question
till I've done it."
And you know, I love that
with things like BigQuery,
so that's really exciting to me.
And then the Cloud
Machine Learning
stuff to see the
future of bringing
to bear some of the
greatest machine learning
or deep learning tools
that are out there
and, you know, where's
Google pushing that needle,
because it's exciting to
see how fast it's evolving.
And that's evolving
as an API that people
like me can access and
do incredible things
without understanding any of
that math behind the scenes.
MARK MANDEL:
Awesome, Well, Kalev,
thank you so much for taking
five minutes of your time
out of your day to
come here, and I
hope you have a great
Cloud Next experience.
KALEV LEETARU: Thanks so much.
It's great to be here, and I'm
excited about the coming week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks, Kalev,
for such an amazing interview.
A bunch of very,
very good sound bites
that marketing will appreciate.
Such an exciting guy.
Next, we have kind of
a continuation of what
Kalev was talking about.
He mentioned that you can
use many of our products
as simple APIs
like Cloud Vision.
But if you want to,
you can actually
dig deeper and basically
go down the text stack
and change things down there.
And we're going
to be talking now
to Tim Kelton from
the Descartes Labs.
They're showing us-- they were
showing us that really cool
de--
it's pretty amazing.
And it involves kind of using
like Vision API but not Vision
API.
Instead, what they did is
they train a new TensorFlow
model for the
specific detections
that they want to do.
So I think that that was
a very interesting topic.
So let's talk to him.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
Let's do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're now
joined by Tim Kelton from--
I always doubt how to
pronounce that if it's
Descartes or Des-carts Labs.
How are you doing, Tim?
TIM KELTON: I'm
doing really good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it is the
second time we have you here
in the podcast, but for those
people that have not heard--
have not listened to
the previous episode,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about who are you,
what do you do?
TIM KELTON: Sure, I'm one of the
co-founders of Descartes Labs,
and we're a startup
focused on machine
learning applied to aerial
and satellite imagery
and then using that to see how
the Earth changes every day.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I know you are here
for the Community Summit,
but you actually just showed us
something super, super awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Our
cool thing of the week.
TIM KELTON: We're
really excited.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, can you tell
us a little about what it is
and what it does?
TIM KELTON: Yes, so this is
just launching right now.
It's at
search@descarteslabs.com,
and we have many petabytes
of satellite imagery
that we've pulled
into Google Cloud.
And then we basically run
machine learning algorithms
over them to do a
similarity search.
So you can think of
dividing the earth up
into really, really
small little squares,
and then looking for something
interesting like a wind
turbine.
And you might say, well, where
else in all of this imagery
are there wind turbines?
And then what we'll do is we
run that back through our models
and run all of the
satellite imagery through,
and we'll return back the
top 500 most similar images
to what we just clicked on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I think
it is pretty interesting
because we were previously
talking with Kalev,
and he was mentioning how he
uses, for his project details,
he uses Cloud Vision and--
but Cloud Vision is
just like a REST API
and you can very easily use it.
If you want to dig
deeper, you can definitely
change, basically, the
engine of how it works.
Is that what you're doing?
Are you running Cloud ML?
Are you running TensorFlow?
Tell us a little bit about it.
TIM KELTON: Yeah, these
are TensorFlow models.
And basically, we
extract a feature vector
for each of those
little tiny scenes
that we see all over the Earth.
And that has a unique signature
and then we rank them,
and we do a similarity in
which other features anywhere
else on the earth are similar.
So it's something you
could never scale--
you could never
hire 1,000 people
to just rank every single
pixel all over the world
and say, how similar is
this to this, you know?
You have to automate it
enough to use something
like TensorFlow.
MARK MANDEL: And I
saw on the demo that--
the demo, the actual app
that you can scale in and out
visually from like
America or China
or basically sort
of other nations.
I believe you're using Google
Cloud Storage for that.
Is that-- what's
happening there?
TIM KELTON: Yeah,
under the hood,
we could never attach enough
PD disks to a single VM
to store all of that imagery.
So we had to have
another solution.
So we're actually storing all
of the compressed and tiled
imagery in Google Cloud
Storage, and then we
have a layer on top of
that called Festivus.
And that's a file system layer
on top of object storage,
and that allows us
system-level access
just as if it was native disk.
And that's really we can only
do that because cloud storage is
just so fast returning
back the objects.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I'm actually curious
about two things.
First, is Festivus--
I don't know how to pronounce
it correctly, but Festivus,
is that open source
by any chance?
TIM KELTON: No, it's just
something we built. Actually,
our CTO wrote all the code
over a weekend, pretty much,
and got it all to
run really well.
And it's just been this really
core part of our infrastructure
to getting it to
scale, and we're still
a pretty small company focused
on building products right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And the second one was, how
are you actually managing this?
You said there was
petabytes of data in use.
I mean, and it just works?
Like is there some
magic going on,
or it's just because
cloud storage is fast?
TIM KELTON: Well,
under the hood,
you know, we're storing lots--
we have a fairly sophisticated
processing pipeline to get all
the images in and have them all
correct and be really
uniform and have
a real nice API in front of it.
But then, in front of that, to
serve it, we have GKE clusters
and managed instance
group clusters
that we horizontally scale.
And then you have front
end load balancers
that are in front of those
instance groups and GKE
clusters.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds
like something we
might want to do a full
episode on at some point soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, why not?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think so.
So if people are
attending Next or possibly
looking out for
recordings later on,
I believe Descartes Labs has
two sessions at Next this year?
TIM KELTON: Sure, if you want
to learn more about Festivus
and how we're doing using Google
Cloud Storage at large scale,
there's a session,
and it's IO242.
That's on Thursday at 5:30,
and then my session is
talking about PostGRES
and how we use PostGRES,
and that's on--
I think, that's IO235
on Thursday at 1:20
or 1:30 something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
We have links to the
demos and your sessions
in the show notes.
And those sessions
will be recorded,
so if you're not attending Next,
don't worry because you can
watch them later on YouTube.
TIM KELTON: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: All
right, well, thanks
so much for joining us
here in our little area
at the Community Summit and
thanks for joining us at Next.
TIM KELTON: Thanks, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Next
up, we are talking
to Veronica Lopez, a
good friend of Francesc,
especially because she
writes a lot of Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
she writes a lot of Go,
and also, she's awesome.
So yeah, we're
going to be talking
to her about all the
cool things that she's
excited for Cloud Next and
cool things that she saw today
the Community Summit.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Let's go do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
very happy to welcome
Veronica Lopez to the podcast.
How are you doing, Veronica?
VERONICA LOPEZ: I'm fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Why don't
you tell us, for some--
like we-- it is weird,
but there's people
that do not know who you are.
Why don't you tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do?
VERONICA LOPEZ:
I'm Veronica Lopez.
Veronica Lopis--
MARK MANDEL: Veronica Lopis--
[LAUGHTER]
VERONICA LOPEZ: And I'm
a software engineer.
I used to be a
physicist, and I want
to be a physicist
again at some point.
But for now, I'm a
software engineer.
And I used to write
mobile apps with Android,
and now I write Go.
And I'm trying to learn Elixir.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we are
today at the Community Summit
for Cloud Next, and we
just finished, basically,
with most of the meetings.
Why don't you tell us
a little bit about it?
What was the best part for you?
VERONICA LOPEZ: Oh,
the best part for me
was the unconference part, where
we got to go to different rooms
and talk to experts
about different stuff.
And in my case, I chose
the machine learning room,
where people, even though
they have lots of experiences
and backgrounds, were--
I don't know, taking baby
steps in the subject,
and everyone had a
lot of questions.
And I honestly
thought that I was
the only ignorant person in the
room, but it wasn't the case.
But it was a positive thing,
because everyone started
talking and asking
genuine questions,
and I didn't ask
anything because they
had my very same questions.
It was interesting.
And, I don't know,
they were concerned
about how a machine learning--
how not to lie to people
with machine learning,
how it is very easy
to do that, and that
started like dancing
in my mind, and now I'm
very worried about that.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds very interesting.
Who was the expert
managing the session?
Do you remember?
VERONICA LOPEZ: I don't
remember his name, but--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
OK, that's fine.
MARK MANDEL: He was good.
If you had to get one
takeaway for anyone who's
listening who wasn't
obviously able to attend,
what would that
one takeaway maybe
that you got from that session?
VERONICA LOPEZ: Well, in
general, the knowledge
that I got from it, but
how Google makes it-- well,
TensorFlow makes it super,
not easy, but approachable,
for people to get into
machine learning stuff.
And how-- well, another
thing was that--
concerning-- well,
regarding this issue
of how not to lie to people
with machine learning
and big data stuff.
Our conclusion was that you
have to use as many tools
as possible, not use
only TensorFlow-- sorry--
and not just math models,
and not just algorithms,
but all of them together to
get to a reliable conclusion.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So tomorrow is the first actual
day of Google Cloud Next.
Are you excited about
any specific session?
VERONICA LOPEZ: Yeah, yours.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Do we
pay her for that?
Is that how that happens?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know.
I'm going to buy
her a beer later.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: What
are you excited
about Francesc's session for?
VERONICA LOPEZ: I am
excited about learning
how to use the Google tools.
I know that that sounds very
general and as if you paid me,
but it's genuine because
I've had the chance
to work with Google
Cloud Platform in so
many ways like for
continuous integration
stuff with the storage
stuff, and many, many things.
And TensorFlow, I was
trying to play with it,
but a lot of times, you have
so many things to do with it,
that you'd-- well,
at least in my case,
I didn't know how to
proceed and what to do.
And most important of all,
like, how to really take
advantage of these tools.
So I am really looking
forward to getting
to know from the experts
how to really take advantage
of all of these resources.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we're going
to have meet the experts booths.
I think they're all around Next.
And also, on top of that,
there's a bunch of code labs
that people can
go and play with.
So I hope that you
will enjoy those.
VERONICA LOPEZ: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Veronica, thank you
so much for joining us,
and I hope you enjoy Cloud Next.
VERONICA LOPEZ: Yay!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
VERONICA LOPEZ: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks to
everyone who joined us today
inside our little
room, our podcast booth
here at the Community Summit.
It was so nice that
you could join us.
Really excited to be
doing daily episodes.
It's going to be really cool
doing this on the floor.
So rather than seeing
you all next week,
we'll see you all tomorrow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup,
talk to you all tomorrow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]